BIG HEALTHY BUCKET OF TRUMP.
SO NOW THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS
MADE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
HE'S GOING TO MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE TOO.
BUT IS THE WORLD READY FOR THAT?
HERE'S TRUMP PULLING A GORDON
RAMSAY AT THE U.N. ABOUT TO TELL
THEM THAT THEIR MENU SUCKS.
>> MY ADMINISTRATION HAS
ACCOMPLISHED MORE THAN ALMOST
ANY ADMINISTRATION IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
DIDN'T EXPECT THAT REACTION, BUT
THAT'S OKAY.
>> LAUGH IF YOU MUST, YOU SMALL
MEANINGLESS BUREAUCRATS.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE LATELY
BESIDES BOOZING ON OUR DIME AND
CHASING HOOKERS?
LOVE IT OR HATE IT, TRUMP IS THE
LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD AND
HE'S READY TO GIVE THE PLANET A
LITTLE TOUGH LOVE.
>> GERMANY WILL BECOME TOTALLY
DEPENDENT ON RUSSIAN ENERGY IF
IT DOES NOT IMMEDIATELY CHANGE
COURSE.
MOVING FORWARD, WE ARE ONLY
GOING TO GIVE FOREIGN AID TO
THOSE WHO RESPECT US.
OPEC NATIONS ARE AS USUAL
RIPPING OFF THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
AND I DON'T LIKE IT.
NOBODY SHOULD LIKE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: NOBODY SHOULD LIKE IT.
HE'S LIKE THE AMERICAN SANTA.
HE'S TELLING THE WORLD WHO HAS
BEEN NAUGHTY AND NICE, BUT
EVERYBODY'S NAUGHTY.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: EVERYBODY ON HIS LIST IS
NAUGHTY.
AND HE'S JUST GETTING STARTED.
>> I DON'T LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN CUBA, AND I CERTAINLY DON'T
LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
VENEZUELA.
IRAN IS GOING TO COME BACK TO ME
AND THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE A
GOOD DEAL, I THINK, MAYBE NOT,
YOU NEVER KNOW.
YEMEN IS A MESS.
SYRIA IS A MESS.
NOT HAPPY WITH OPEC.
I LIKE CHINA, AND I LIKE
PRESIDENT XI A LOT.
I THINK HE'S A FRIEND OF MINE.
HE MAY NOT BE A FRIEND OF MINE
ANYMORE.
GREG: HE'S GOT AN OPINION ON
EVERYONE.
TO HIM EARTH IS JUST ANOTHER
LOCATION FOR CELEBRITY
APPRENTICE.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: CUBA YOU'RE FIRED.
AND OF COURSE THERE'S THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA.
THEY PLAY HARD TO GET.
IT IS LIKE A GEOPOLITICAL
VERSION OF ROSS AND RACHEL FROM
"FRIENDS".
>> -- SAYING THAT CHINA HAS
TOTAL RESPECT FOR DONALD TRUMP
AND FOR DONALD TRUMP'S VERY VERY
LARGE BRAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: FOR A MINUTE THERE, FOR A
MINUTE THERE, YOU THOUGHT IT
WASN'T GOING TO BE BRAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THAT PAUSE HE DID WAS
AMAZING.
AND WHO COULD FORGET THE LETTER,
THE MAGNIFICENT LETTERS?
>> HE SAID THIS IS ACTUALLY A
GROUND BREAKING LETTER.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE -- THIS IS
A HISTORIC LETTER.
HE WROTE ME TWO OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL LETTERS.
I HAVE RECEIVED TWO LETTERS FROM
CHAIRMAN KIM.
THEY ARE INCREDIBLE LETTERS.
THEY'RE LETTERS THAT ARE
MAGNIFICENT.
GREG: THAT IS SOME LETTER.
I THINK IT WAS THE LETTERS, D
AND T, AND BOY HE GAVE IT TO THE
KURDS.
>> YOU SAID FROM WHERE?
>> NORTH OF IRAQ.
I'M A KURD.
>> GOOD, GOOD, GREAT PEOPLE.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>> GREAT PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
ARE YOU A KURD?
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: ARE YOU A KURD?
I'M JUST GOING TO ASK THAT TO
EVERYBODY.
AND EVEN CANADA DIDN'T GET OUT
WITHOUT A KICK IN THE
CRANBERRIES.
>> YOU REJECTED A ONE-ON-ONE
WITH JUSTIN TRUDEAU
>> YEAH I DID.
>> WHY
>> I TOLD HIM TO FORGET ABOUT
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: IT'S LIKE HE'S TALKING TO
HIS PLUMBER.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: NOT AN ACTUAL WORLD
LEADER, WELL, CANADA, ANYWAY.
SO WHO'S GREAT NOW?
>> YOU KNOW WHO'S GREAT NOW?
WE'RE GREAT NOW.
GREG: THAT'S RIGHT, WHICH IS WHY
HE'S NOW INTO CHANGING THE
WORLD.
LIKE A REAL ESTATE DEVELOPER.
HE'S DONE WITH ONE PROJECT, THE
UNITED STATES, AND HE'S MOVING
ON TO ANOTHER.
THIS IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT,
NONE OF THIS STUFF HE'S TALKING
ABOUT INVOLVES MILITARY FORCE
AND SHOULDN'T THAT BE SOMETHING
THAT LEFTIES EMBRACE AND LOVE
ABOUT THIS GUY?
INSTEAD OF FLEXING MILITARY
MUSCLE, HE TOYS WITH THE FAILING
"NEW YORK TIMES".
STAND UP, GO AHEAD.
>> THE FAILING "NEW YORK TIMES"
STAND UP GO AHEAD.
I THINK ABC, CBS, NBC, THE
TIMES -- THEY ARE ALL GOING TO
ENDORSE ME BECAUSE IF THEY
DON'T, THEY'RE GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ME?
GREG: NO WE CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
AT ALL.
SO ALL IN ALL, HE REALIZES FOR
AMERICA TO BE GREATER, YOU KNOW,
EARTH NEEDS A LITTLE WORK TOO.
AND HE'S WILLING TO LEAD THE
ENTERPRISE PEACEFULLY.
WHAT COULD BE THE POSSIBILITIES?
>> GET READY FOR THE MOST
GLOBALLY ELECTRIFYING EVENT
EVER.
HE'S MADE AMERICA GREAT AND NOW
DONALD THE DIPLOMATIC MASTERMIND
TRUMP IS TAKING THE BATTLE
INTERNATIONAL BY IMPROVING --
MOPPING UP VENICE, REPLACING
WINDMILLS IN HOLLAND WITH COAL
MINES, MAKING BIG BEN A DIGITAL
CLOCK, MOUNT EVEREST WITH A
ESCALATOR, DECORATING THE GREAT
WALL OF CHINA WITH A PAINTING,
FIXING THE LEANING TOWER WITH A
TEAM OF CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
WILL TRUMP FINALLY FIX THE
BROKEN LIBERTY BELL OR PUT A
MORE AWESOME FACE ON MOUNT RUSH
MORE?
GET YOUR TICKETS NOW TO FIND
OUT.
THE FIRST 100 GUESTS GET --
[INAUDIBLE] -- SIGNED BY DONALD
TRUMP.
>> IT IS THE TRUMP VERSUS THE
U.N. WORLD REBOOT AWESOME
EXTRAVAGANZA.
GREG: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE'S SO BRIGHT THE NORTH STAR
CALLS HER FOR ADVICE ATTORNEY
AND TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISORY
BOARD MEMBER MADISON GESIOTTO.
HE'S SO SMART IT HURTS.
WASHINGTON TIMES OPINION EDITOR
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR CHARLIE
HURT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SHE'S SO BRIGHT SHE
MOONLIGHTS AS MOONLIGHT, REVIEW
REPORTER KAT TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AND HIS NEIGHBORS ALL HAVE
EARTHQUAKE INSURANCE.
FORMER WWE SUPERSTAR MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: CHARLES, IT'S SO
INTERESTING WHEN THERE ARE
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE AND THEY ACT LIKE IT
IS SOME KIND OF WEIRD FREAK
SHOW, AND I'M LOOKING AT IT, AND
I'M GOING I'M WATCHING A GUY
WITH AN INCREDIBLY NIMBLE MIND
BOUNCE ALL OVER EVERY SINGLE
ISSUE AND TALK ABOUT FIXING THEM
AS THOUGH IT'S A CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT.
>> YEAH.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT ALSO, I MEAN,
THE GUY'S COMEDIC TIMING IS
JUST -- IT IS KILLER.
WHEN HE DID THE THING ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT HOW GREAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS, AND EVERYBODY
LAUGHED, AND IN THIS ROOM
EVERYBODY LAUGHED, THEY LAUGHED
AT THE EXACT RIGHT TIME, THE GUY
TOTALLY GETS IT.
IT'S THAT HUMOR THAT -- AND OF
COURSE ALL THESE DESPITS IN THE
WORLD AND IN THE ROOM WHO GOT IT
JUST PROVING THAT OF COURSE THE
PRESS HAS LESS OF A SENSE OF
HUMOR THAN DESPOTS AROUND THE
WORLD.
BUT THE OTHER THING IS THAT
BASICALLY THE ATTACK ON DONALD
TRUMP RIGHT NOW IS THAT HE'S NOT
PERFECT.
THAT'S WHAT UPSETS THEM.
SO WHEN HE GOES AND TALKS -- AND
MEETS WITH KIM JONG-UN, KIM
JONG-IL, THE COMPLAINT IS YOU
HAVEN'T GOTTEN PEACE FAST
ENOUGH.
ABSOLUTELY THE GUY CAN'T WIN.
THEY CONSTANTLY -- THEY DID THIS
THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO DO IT.
THEY CONSTANTLY MOVE THE GOAL
POST.
GREG: CHARLIE BRINGS UP A GOOD
POINT WHICH IS RARE, MADISON.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THE MEDIA IS WRONG ABOUT
TRUMP BECAUSE THEY THINK THAT
THE WORLD FINDS HIM COMICAL OR
WEIRD, BUT I HAVE A THEORY THAT
A LOT OF THE WORLD ISN'T LIKE
MANHATTAN.
THE WORLD IS PRETTY OLD SCHOOL
ALPHA.
THEY ARE LIKE 30 YEARS, 40 YEARS
BACK WHEN PEOPLE -- WHEN THE
WORLD LEADERS WERE LIKE TRUMP.
SO HE'S KIND OF ENTERTAINING OR
REFRESHING OR SOMETHING.
THAT'S MY THEORY.
FEEL FREE TO IGNORE IT AND
ANSWER THE OWN QUESTION THAT
MIGHT BE IN YOUR MIND.
>> I THINK IT WAS VERY FUNNY AT
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE.
I THINK HE'S HILARIOUS A LOT OF
THE TIMES.
I THINK HE'S VERY SUCCESSFUL AND
THAT'S THE THING THE MEDIA FAILS
TO REPORT ON.
LOOK AT THE EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL
WEEK WITH U.N. THIS WEEK.
OPENED TRADE TALKS WITH JAPAN.
OF COURSE GOING AFTER CHINA WHO
NO PRESIDENT BEFORE IN 25 YEARS
HAS REALLY GONE AFTER FOR THEIR
UNFAIR TRADE PRACTICES.
THEY SAID YOU KNOW HE COULD
NEVER HAVE PEACE IN CERTAIN
AREAS, GUESS WHAT?
LOOK WHAT HE'S DOING WITH NORTH
KOREA.
ONLY THE BEGINNING THERE.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE IGNORING THE
FACT THAT HE'S BEEN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL, JUDGING HIM ON WORDS
INSTEAD OF ACTIONS AND RESULTS.
GREG: UH-HUH.
OKAY KAT, I MEAN, LET'S FACE IT,
HE'S CHANGING THE WORLD WITHOUT
BOMBS.
AND I MEAN THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I
WOULD CALL PROGRESS, MAYBE?
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I DO LIKE ABOUT HIM IS THAT HE
TENDS TO WANT TO USE DIPLOMACY
AND TALKING AND MAKING DEALS
RATHER THAN JUST GOING TO WAR
WITH EVERYONE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS VERY INTERESTING IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
HE WAS RUNNING AGAINST HILARY
CLINTON EVEN THOUGH SHE WAS A
DEMOCRAT, SHE WAS A NEO
DEMOCRAT.
I THINK WE WOULD BE AT WAR RIGHT
NOW IN PLACES THAT WE'RE NOT AT
WAR IF WE HAD HILARY CLINTON AS
PRESIDENT INSTEAD OF DONALD
TRUMP.
GREG: PROBABLY WITH CANADA.
>> WE MIGHT BE AT WAR WITH
CANADA.
GREG: YEAH, AUSTRALIA.
ANY THOUGHTS?
>> I MEAN, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ROSS AND RACHEL AGAIN.
GREG: OKAY, GO AHEAD.
>> I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN THAT LONG FOR THEM TO WORK
IT OUT.
GREG: THAT IS TRUE.
THAT'S GETTING A SMATTERING OF
APPLAUSE.
>> THEY WERE ON A BREAK.
>> WHEN HE SPEAKS TO THE WORLD,
WHEN HE GIVES HIS SPEECHES, A
LOT LIKE SOMEONE WHO JUST BEAT
THE ONE ON A CASE, BUT HE SHOWS
UP AT A BARBECUE, I KNOW WHAT
EVERYONE DID BUT I'M HERE.
THE LAUGHING IS A LOT OF NERVOUS
LAUGHING.
GREG: THAT'S TRUE.
>> HE'S COMING FROM A PLACE OF
POWER AND I THINK HE'S PROBABLY
ONE -- I CAN'T REMEMBER A
PRESIDENT WHO CHOSE TO USE IT.
LIKE LISTEN TO ME WHEN I SPEAK.
GREG: YEAH.
>> IF YOU DON'T, YOU'RE GOING TO
WISH YOU HAD.
IT'S VERY UNDERLYING.
HE KIND OF TALKS IN A WAY VERY
SIMILAR LIKE WHEN SOMEONE
BORROWS MONEY FROM ME AND THEY
DON'T PAY IT BACK.
GREG: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> HE APPEALS TO YOUR SENSES,
LIKE SAY, FOR EXAMPLE, JOE YOU
LIKE WALKING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JOE WILL SAY YES I DO.
WELL, FOR YOU TO CONTINUE TO DO
SO, YOU NEED TO PAY ME THE MONEY
I LENT YOU PLUS 10%.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT IS HOW HE TALKS TO THE
WORLD, AND I THINK THEY GET IT.
JOE GOT IT.
GREG: YEAH, YEAH, JOE GOT IT.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: IS HE WALKING?
>> JOE?
HE WILL BE FINE.